I saw an interesting post on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash
reddit titled is Hillary Clinton
president and I thought it was an
interesting post because at this point
the obsession from the right with
Hillary Clinton is almost as if she were
President of the United States and not
Donald Trump and I know that she did get
millions more votes than Donald Trump in
the 2016 election but the president is
Donald Trump and even the President
himself continues to be obsessed with
Hillary Clinton tweeting about her
endlessly Fox News keeps talking about
Hillary's uranium one scandal a Hillary
investigation when will we finally know
the truth about Hillary this or Hillary
that and there are even a number of
youtubers who I've mentioned before some
of them are sort of making a business
out of criticizing and supposedly
debunking me some of them are also still
talking about if and when or for what
reason is Hillary Clinton going to be
indicted and it's happening to such a
degree and so constantly that if a
foreigner who wasn't following American
politics came to the United States they
check into their hotel they walk through
their hotel lobby and lo and behold that
happens to be Fox News that's on in the
hotel lobby they might actually think
that Hillary Clinton is President of the
United States because of the constant
focus on her by right-wing media rather
than what is actually being done by this
administration and there's a couple
different interpretations here one is
that the Hillary in an orange jumpsuit
conspiracies as I call them they're just
good for ratings and good for business
right the Fox News audience eats it up
and when I say the Fox News audience I
don't literally mean just Fox News I
mean people who primarily get their news
from Fox News or Alex Jones or Rush
Limbaugh whatever whatever you want to
insert there they've been primed for
years to expect Hillary Clinton to be
indicted and put in prison any day now
so it could just be a matter of it's
good for ratings and it does well with
them it titillates an excite
them there's another explanation for the
focus on Hillary Clinton though it's
more cynical and it relates more to the
propaganda motive than the ratings modem
which is that it's a desperate attempt
not to cover and not to inform Trump's
base about the endless scandals and
possible crimes of the Trump
administration and it's all funny and
silly make fun of the stupid right-wing
media and its followers but it has a
real impact because when the focus is on
Hillary Clinton on so much of right-wing
media it reduces the appetite for
holding Trump to account right if people
don't know what's going on with the
actual president the real administration
and instead they're focused on uranium
one Benghazi who knows what her emails
there's going to be no impetus for
actually holding the people from Trump's
administration accountable so I think
it's really easy for us to laugh it off
say look at those stupid brainwashed
people who think what Fox News's agenda
is actually reflects what's happening in
this country but it has a real impact
and we we may see it and I would argue
we're already seeing it and that a lot
of people just aren't worried about what
Trump is doing because they have no clue
what it is that Trump is doing I don't
think we can laugh this off well I think
as far as Fox News is concerned there
has to be a boogeyman right and for the
longest time they had the Democrats they
had Barack Obama they had Hillary
Clinton yep and now Republicans are in
charge of everything Congress the
presidency they got it all so they have
to find something and you know sometimes
they'll focus on the news media but you
can't really single in on any specific
person you're not gonna yes ice Brian
seltzer Brooke Baldwin all over and over
again you gotta go with a Hillary
Clinton although Trump has had some
success in just making the media the
enemy other than of course Fox News was
just doing really really great work
according to him there is always two
layers to these disinformation and
propaganda campaigns and it's very easy
for us on the Left to initially react by
just saying haha how stupid are they but
once we realize right that for every one
of them who has no idea what's going on
we need to make up for that person by
getting someone out to the vote in order
to counter that vote
so the problem we're facing is that it
is a bigger issue than just talking
about the issues it's the entire
narrative that's framed by propaganda
and propagandists who seek to defend
Trump and I've talked about this before
there's actually a couple slides from my
classes that have done at Boston College
and some of my public speaking where I
talk about degrees of informational
incongruity level one of informational
incongruity is we know about an issue we
recognize its importance and we disagree
on the issue so for the example of
abortion we have people who say abortion
should be legal and safe and others who
say abortion is illegal but everybody
agrees abortion is an issue and it is an
important issue level two of
informational incongruity would be a
debate as to the importance of an issue
so on gay marriage as an example you
could have some who say gay marriage is
an important issue and others who say it
is not you need to agree about the
importance of an issue in order to
discuss your positions and the most
dangerous level of informational
incongruity is what I call level 3 and
that is where people are unaware of
something as an issue altogether climate
change I haven't heard about that
Russian collusion with Trump not
something I'm aware of because I'm
watching Fox News and they're talking
about Hillary and uranium one we are
seeing level three of informational
incongruity on many issues in the United
States right now and it's media like fox
news and info wars and many many others
that are perpetrating that that are
creating that degree of informational
incongruity send me your thoughts about
this really important issue I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the shows on Twitter
at David Pakman show great to be back in
studio and we have many more stories to
talk about today today's program is made
possible in part by futur futur is a
social forecasting game where you
compete with other players to predict
the future and it's built on the
principles of what's called a prediction
market a scientifically proven way of
using the wisdom of the crowd to create
more accurate predictions about future
events prediction markets have been
shown to work much better than other
forecasting methods like polling or
for analysis in many cases and futur has
actually taken the concept and turned it
into a fun easy to use social game you
open up the futur app and you'll see a
whole range of forecasts covering topics
across the board from politics to sports
and everything in between
you can check out my predictions and
follow me to get updates on my profile
which is linked to in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube the tour
is a great tool to find out more about
the world improve your forecasting
ability show off your prediction skills
to friends and even better when you make
predictions on futur you're helping to
create more accurate forecasts for
everybody their mission of creating
better predictions is great and actually
going in there and seeing how well you
can do at predicting the future can be
kind of addicting go to futur com sign
up and start making forecast it's free
and it's available on both Android and
iOS as well as on web browsers and
that's f you t you you are calm